dans la news est ce que tu peux aller
c'est vrai mais c'est génial je suis
agathe langlois et j'appelle pour
connaître le lieu de ma titularisation
ruy héros isidro c'est sur la ligne ça
non comment ça très loin sur l'a8
allez zou en picardie c'est vous bon
sang à truchtersheim et polyglotte et
pourquoi telle saillie j'ai trouvé à me
loger chez l'habitant à gauche et
gilbert hockey non non en quelle année
la balade continue
le téléphone vous m'aviez parlé d'un
studio indépendant quand vous fermez la
porte à ces indépendants ok donc on part
son premier jour merde
bienvenue à notre nouvelle professeure
d'anglais toute épreuve de maths et ça
ça se voit doté parisienne ça
[Musique]
tu vois tu me donnes ton carnet
immédiatement puis oui dit mais tu peux
dire oui
united tech a fabriqué et qui sont ces
gens je te donne jusqu'à noël pour
rentrer chez toi se passera pas l'hiver
mais l'endroit comme les gens primo
parce que vous savez comment elle dit la
dernière campagne si jeune homme a été
commandé une casquette
quatre spectacles et le quarté quinté tu
vas pas démissionné porto por tu aimes
ce métier de merde si vous l'essayez
vous pouvoir bonne c'est un gamin par
décennie j'aurai réussi mon but elle est
mignonne en fait la parisienne qu'il
aime bien parce que sinon je me
maintiens c'est vrai que ça tant que ça
dépend